herr zastrow wir haben gerade gehört
katterbach vorher sogar ein rücktritt
was sagen sie denn zu so eine aussage
von den präsidenten der
bundesärztekammer
ja ich habe die sendung gestern auch
gesehen und ich dachte ich falle vom
stuhl als er das gesagt hat und das auch
noch eine weile verteidigt hat nachher
ist ja dann ein bisschen zurückgerudert
und hat eigentlich das rumgeeiert also
nein es kann ja überhaupt gar nicht sein
dass der präsident der bundesärztekammer
hingeht und sagt die masken nutzen nicht
oder sind sehr fragwürdig also die ganze
politik und alle die sich hier bemühen
die cholera epidemie in den griff zu
bekommen versuchen den leute davon zu
überzeugen dass die maske getragen wird
und jetzt kommt auf einmal ein arzt
daher und sagt ja keine evident ist muss
man natürlich dazu folgendes sagen was
herr einer hat vielleicht verkennt aber
jene scheint ihn ohnehin ein wenig fremd
zu sein
das ist ja eine präventionsmaßnahme eine
präventivmedizin die wir haben und eine
evidenz kriegen sie nur hin indem sie
eine studie machen und in dem sie jetzt
zum beispiel 100 leute operieren mit
mund nasen schutz und 100 leute ohne um
und nasenschutz oder sie gehen in ein
zimmer eines erkrankten der an
tuberkulose erkrankte auch wieder 100
personen mit und so 100 personen und
ohne mund nasen und hinter erzählen sie
wie viele infektionen wir haben bzw wie
viel an vom personal erkrankt sind
dann mach doch kein mensch mit erstmal
würde die ethikkommission eines
krankenhauses sowas überhaupt nicht
zulassen
und zweitens muss ja der mitarbeiter
müssen ja alle wieder mitmachen waren
gefragt werden ob sie das überhaupt
mitmachen würden das kann ich mir schwer
vorstellen dass jemand also der patient
der ist operiert wird ohne mund nasen
schutz der wird wahrscheinlich eher die
den fragenden den vogel zeigen und der
mitarbeiter der jetzt ohne moralische
zum offenen tobacco lösen hingehen soll
naja da wird auch nicht allzu viele von
geben ich will also damit nur sagen dann
ist gar keine evidenz herzustellen
weil solche versuche im prinzip nicht zu
machen sind
abgesehen davon den nagel schutz gibt es
seit 1870 75 so in den dreck ja da hat
ein arzt sich demo nasenschutz
umgebunden weil er sich geärgert habe
über die vielen infektionen die hatte
und siehe da nach dem eher demo
nasenschutz getan hat sind die
infektionen
ob also um 70 prozent auf 30 prozent
zurückgegangen und dann hat man das nie
wieder verlassen und das ist ja auch gut
so also so ein quatsch zu erzählen dass
die maske nichts hilft in dieser phase
auch gerade ja das ist eigentlich
unverantwortlich
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schaue ich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren